[Musique]
on fait partie de ceux qui se
rassemblent pas aux quatre axes en place
rue de nattes sandra bonjour je
m'appelle camilla j'ai 22 ans et je fais
des vidéos sur check up
[Musique]
j'ai fait mes preuves quand quelqu'un a
dénoncé les clichés que les personnes
avaient sur leur handicap fait un rouge
avant de casser ce que je suis affecté
les les réduire à néant des gens en
général et quatre cette idée en tête
comme quoi tout le monde les personnes
en situation d'handicap plus vie
forcément mal et ça a fait quelque chose
que justement j'aimerais changer comme
on peut très bien payés de manière très
joyeuse sans être à 100 sa victime
[Musique]
j'ai la maladie charcot marie tooth nom
barbare je peux plus du tout marché mais
je peux encore bouger mes jambes
mais avant ce stade peut empêcher les
chiens les orteils les poêler les doigts
paralysé
une
quand j'avais 18 ans j'ai j'étais en
terminale j'allais passer mon bac es mon
estomac se fait retourner sur lui même
donc j'ai failli mourir car il a failli
exploser
j'ai que trois mois de cours six mois de
convalescence
donc pour moi c'était quasi impossible
alors de mecs je suis quand même mal aux
épreuves surprises
j'ai eu mon bac avec mention assez bien
alexion mois d'absence
camara sur deux là ça a été le déclic je
me suis dit si ça c'est possible
rien est impossible
[Musique]
sur ce que j'ai à prix de départ cette
expérience c'est que quand vous vraiment
quelque chose on relevait dans les
tripes
sur les réseaux sociaux et j'envoie être
plus facilement à amen de poser des
questions comment tu te lèves le matin
comment tu t'appelles tu fais ici
quand tu te coiffe la boîte ils sont
avec vous plus à l'aise sur les
patientes être franc je dis ça je change
les idées je change la perception du
handicap il ça pour moi c'est la
meilleure des récompenses